We're going to look at
an example of inference attack
with the database that we defined by
the schema that we just discussed.
The query that we're going to
consider here is a query that returns
the average score on an exam.
Okay, so
any student should be able to find out.
In fact,
that's the first question after an exam,
when you bring back the grades,
students ask what was the average.
So any student should be able to submit
a query that returns the average,
of the score, on that exam.
And the average basically is,
we take every student's grade,
sum it up, and then divide it
by the number of students.
And that shouldn't tell us anything
about a particular student.
Remember what you're not authorized
to access is somebody else's grade.
This is an authorized query and
our idea of inference attack is
that when you use a query like this
to gain access to information that
you normally are not allowed to see.
If you are an attacker, your goal
would be to gain access to information
that is not available to you.
So that would be to find the exact
score of some other student.
It's not your score that you already
know, but if you are an outsider,
of course you're targeting a particular
student, and you want to find out his or
her exact score.
That's the goal of the attacker or
the information that we want
the attacker to get access to.
Inference attacks sometimes
require some additional outside or
external information.
So maybe the attacker does
know when somebody takes,
some person takes the exam late.
Could be because they were sick or
something like that,
so the whole class took
the exam on a certain date, and
after a few days after that, perhaps,
this student is going to take the exam.
And this information is
available to that hacker.
So that hacker is going to do in this
case is run the average score query,
before this one student,
the one who takes the exam late actually
takes the exam and his or
her score is added to the database.
So before the exam is taken,
the score may be zero or
something like that and after the exam,
it's replaced by the correct value.
So that attacker is running
the average query which we said
should be allowed before this
one student takes the exam.
And the attacker knows when
the student has taken the exam,
maybe tries a few times, eventually
sees maybe a different average value.
Or, after a certain amount of time, we
know that the exam must have been taken
by everyone, including this one
student who had missed it earlier.
So it does the average again.
Okay, so now I have two averages,
and let's say this student is Alice.
So the average score,
not including Alice, and
then average score of
everyone that includes Alice.
So based on these two values that are
returned by this query that is allowed,
I can now figure out
what Alice's average is.
Actually it's fairly easy to do that,
if there are n number of students,
the total score, if you add them all up,
is n times the average.
So here, since Alice hasn't taken, so
it'll be n-1 times the average
of the score before,
the total of the scores before, and
this is after Alice takes the exam.
The difference is Alice's grade exactly.
Okay so the idea here is that these
two queries both are allowed,
because they return the average.
The database system allows that hacker
to run each one of these queries by
running these queries
at particular times.
You have to think through when
exactly you want to do that.
We are able to make an inference and
find the exact
value of the target score, just by
the difference that I just mentioned.
So, this is the example of an inference
attack where you use authorized
queries to gain access to information
that you're not authorized for.
So, which is the exact
score of the target,
in this case the target was Alice